today here in brussels the
governments are presenting a
five-year national plan on recovery
and the consolidation of peace drawn up
in consultation with the population is
even more collaboration with the
european union the united nations and the
world bank
this afternoon my colleague commissioner
me doctors we will be the contribution
of the european union which has considerable
or even double compared to the period
2008 2013
this church has caused a lot of
discussions this is why
through a participatory process
we have from the moment we take office
and burn it a a strategy shared
by all
we came to ask our friends to
those who have not always supported come
and help us support us to finance so
this strategy yes we
discussed this morning by putting aside
the world bank which goes beyond  of 500
million dollars over the next
three years
what we are trying to do next to
the authorities is
exactly to establish and help
the state helped to assist the government
to rebuild confidence in the country